monsieur le président merci la
commission s'est bien gardée d'exercer
une pression quelconque sur monsieur
masson pour l'amener à défendre ces
amendements en commission la une ne
s'est pas rendue pour le faire donc nous
respectons totalement sa liberté de
comportement
je comprends pour cette raison il
souhaite que la commission puisse se
réunir puisqu'il a un peu de retard à
rattraper dans les exposer ses arguments
de journaux plus sérieusement je
voudrais indiquer que la question de la
clandestinité si j'ose dire des
parrainages qu'il nous propose n'est pas
conforme à l'éprît à l'esprit qu'on peut
se faire de la république
la logique est un élu assume ses
responsabilités si la constitution a
confié au maire et à d'autres élus le
soin de pouvoir parrainer un candidat
c'est qu'ils en assument naturellement
la responsable ajoute et je crois qu'il
sera sensible à cet argument lui qui
soutenons nicolas dupont taignons doit
par conséquent avoir des références plus
solide que les miennes s'agissant du
général de gaulle et de la fondation de
la vème république que celui ci n'a
jamais souhaité la prolifération de
candidats mais bien au contraire que
l'élection présidentielle permettent de
distinguer entre les grands courants
d'opinion le plus rapidement possible
celui qui permettra d'exercer la
responsabilité la plus haute de l'état
j'ajoute enfin que l'ensemble des
violences auquel il fait allusion et des
pressions qu'il évoque peuvent
parfaitement être sanctionnés
aujourd'hui dans le cadre du code pénal
et que si la connaissance d' infractions
qui ont été commises sur des élus qui
aura été dissuadés de pouvoir présenter
leurs parrainages ou qui auraient été
ensuite menacé pour l'avoir fait qu'il
doit effectivement saisir la justice qui
a tous les moyens aujourd'hui pour punir
ce genre de situation à linverse si l'on
devait adopter les amendements qui nous
présentera tout à l'heure on risque
d'arriver à une situation un chef de
parti ne pourra plus de lettres consigne
à ses adhérents ça tomberait sous le
coup de la loi
ce qui serait même paradoxal car on peut
pas s'étonner qu'un chef de parti puisse
inciter les élus qui se recommandent du
même parti que lui ou quelqu'un que vous
avez mis en cause
madame aubry on peut pas s'étonner
qu'elle donne des indications qui
consiste à assurer la cohérence des
soutiens qui sont importés vous avez
sans doute le souvenir comme nous et
peut-être moins douloureusement que nous
de ce qui s'est passé lors de l'élection
présidentielle de 2002 où la
multiplication des candidats s'est
traduit par le fait que le second tour a
privé beaucoup de nos concitoyens d'un
vrai choix
merci madame le ministre
l'avis du gouvernement et si monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs avant de m'exprimer sur cet
envoi sur ce renvoi en commission je
voudrais simplement rappeler le contexte
ce projet de l'oise et dire qu'il
s'inscrit dans le plan d'économie voulue
par le gouvernement présenté par
françois fillon et qu'à ce titre nous
avons tous cette responsabilité de
vouloir réduire les dépenses publiques
dans le contexte budgétaire et financier
que nous connaissons bien
alors à ce titre même si on est tenté de
répondre par rapport aux interrogations
des uns et des autres moi je voudrais
dire en préambule que je ne vais pas
pour la sérénité des débats alimenté
tous les commentaires qui porte sur les
financements des partis politiques et
encore plus ceux qui sont relatés dans
la presse donc
s'agissant du renvoi en commission
effectivement ce que je note c'est que
le ce renvoi indique que la procédure
d'urgence ne serait pas justifiée non
elle est parfaitement juste yale est
justifié pour deux raisons parce que la
procédure de recueil effectivement des
parrainages va commencer à la fin du
mois de février et que le conseil d'état
dans son avis a rappelé combien il était
important pour les candidats d'avoir le
niveau du plafond des ressources et puis
sur cette question des parrainages je ne
vais pas épiloguer je dis simplement
qu'il existe depuis de nombreuses années
et que le rapporteur l'a rappelé et si à
des pressions qui sont faites à
l'encontre des élus aujourd'hui dans le
cadre du droit commun c'est tout à fait
fonctionnel donc il appartient de saisir
les autorités judiciaires bien merci je
vous rappelle qu'aucune explication de
vote nets admise
je vais donc consulté sénat sur la
motion de renvoi la commission déposée
par monsieur jean louis masson que ceux
qui sont pour ce renvoi lève la main
ceux qui sont contre le renvoi n'est
donc pas adoptée
ils ont donc passé à la discussion des
articles l'article unique ctu
d'amendements numéro 15 de monsieur
garçons nom de la commission des lois
oui merci monsieur le président cet
amendement a été adopté par notre
commission elle fait suite effectivement
à un débat que nous avons eu et qui a
été longuement évoquée dans les
interventions général et sur lesquels
par conséquent je ne vais pas développer
qui consiste à rappeler comme d'ailleurs
l'a souhaité le président de la
commission des comptes de campagne et du
financement de la vie politique
les candidats à leur obligation d'une
part et la nécessité et d'autre part de
faire en sorte que l'ensemble des
dépenses qui ne sont amenés engagés dans
le cadre de la campagne puisse être
retracés dans le conte afin que la
commission puisse faire tout à fait
normalement son travail c'est à dire
éventuellement sortir certaines dépenses
de ses comptes
l'objectif est de donner évidemment à ce
dispositif à la fois un caractère
éthique mais aussi préventif ou
dissuasif
c'est la logique dans lequel nous nous
trouvons c'est à dire mettre interne ou
ne pas encourager des comportements qui
consisterait manifestement à se lancer
dans des initiatives auxquelles il est
fait allusion par plusieurs de mes
collègues dont la asia ni et jean yves
le conte les initiatives qui
manifestement jette le trouble dans
l'esprit de l'opinion où il ya à
l'évidence confusion entre les dépenses
engagées au titre d'un mandat et les
dépenses qui devraient être engagées
dans le cadre de la campagne électorale
donc il nous semble que dans le cadre
organique se rappelle serait le bienvenu
merci mais je vais donner d'abord la
parole à monsieur masson qui s'est
inscrite sur l'article qui n'ait pas été
signalée par l'illumination
oui mais j'ai brillant je remercie parce
que j'avais demandé tout à l'heure à
être inscrits sur l'article un bon si
j'ai demandé à être inscrits c'est parce
que le règlement du sénat est ainsi fait
que quand il ya une motion
de procédure d'une motion de renvoi une
motion une question préalable ou autres
les n'importe quel parlementaire peut
intervenir pour une explication de vote
s'il appartient à un groupe politique
parce que les groupes par le politique
ont du temps des explications de vote
par contre les sénateurs non inscrit non
aucun temps enfin non non pas de
possibilité d'intervenir en réponse ou
enfin en explications de vote alors
étant quand même concerné directement
par cette motion
je souhaitais répondront formuler des
avis sur ce cas sur les l'argumentaire
avancé par notre rapporteur et donc je
m'inscris sur certains sujets inscrits
sur cet article 1 en sachant très bien
que ça serait pour moi l'occasion de
dire un petit peu ce que je pense du
système alors quand on voit quand on
entend plutôt les propos tenus par notre
rapporteur en réponse à ma motion de
renvoi
on comprend très bien que compte tenu de
la majorité écrasante que revint que
possèdent les deux partis principaux au
sein de la commission des lois
c'est absolument inutile d'aller
défendre quoique ce soit en commission
des lois est l'intérêt de lire les
défendre en séance publique et de dire
ce que je pense dans le cas d'une motion
de renvoi sait au moins que ces publics
parce que si c'est pour dire quelque
chose au fond des des bureaux calfeutrer
de la commission des lois qui sont
d'ailleurs très sympathique
je pense que ça sert pas à grand chose
deuxièmement je pense que quand on cite
le président de la république
en dix ans le général de gaulle voulait
lui même limité le nombre des candidats
personne n'est contre le fait de limiter
le nombre de candidats c'est pas ça du
tout le débat c'est une fausse réponse
est une réponse hypocrite car le
problème des parrainages c'est que par
le bret le biais de pressions sur les
parents on parvient même à essayer on
parvient non pas même au gardien surtout
à essayer d'empêcher la candidature de
personnes qui serait gênant parce qu'ils
font bon résultat et c'est pas du tout
les parrainages comme je les ai bien
expliqué les parrainages n'ont jamais
empêché monsieur luc chagnon ou
quelqu'un qui n'est pas qui n'a aucune
revente activités de faire c'est moi
parce que les grands partis s'en moque
ah si demain
vous apportez votre parrainage un
illustre inconnu ça dérange personne
par contre quand les grands partis
interviennent quand madame aubry fait
des pressions c'est pour éviter que les
parrainages puisse aller sur des gens
qui puissent faire de l'ombre à tel ou
tel alors ou à l'autre des grands partis
concernés et vous avez donné tout à
l'heure l'exemple de la démocratie en
disant oui maintient les parrainages
il faut justement que ce soit public
comme ça on dissuade les gens de
parrainer et saint yvi ça aurait évité
que en 2002 et bien il y est monsieur le
pen au deuxième tour mais c'est
extrêmement grave des propos de ce type
parce que ça revient à dire que disons
en magouillant par le biais des
parrainages
on aurait pu empêcher monsieur le pen
d'être candidat alors se glorifier de la
publicité des parrainages en disant que
cette publicité contribuer à empêcher
des situations on aurait par exemple
monsieur le pen au deuxième tour
ça revient à prendre les millions de
français qui ont voté pour monsieur le
pen au second pas au premier tour pour
des sites ou des citoyens de seconde
zone et que ma foi bien sonné et puis on
aurait bien empêcher les ces gens là
d'avoir une représentation
alors moi je le dis très clair si le
front national est un parti légal il
faut l'interdire mais si le front
national est un parti légal il est
intolérable que par le biais de diverses
magouilles et d'artifices juridique du
inqualifiable eh bien on essaie on
empêche les millions de français qui
sont prêts à voter pour eux de pouvoir
voter pour eux merci mon cher collègue
de co reprendre leurs discussions
d'amendements dont quel est l'avis du
gouvernement sur l'amendement numéro 15
présenter monsieur gore si les quelques
instants sur l'amendement de monsieur
gorce
aujourd'hui la jurisprudence clarifie
les dépenses qui relève des dépenses
électorales et qui font bien la
différence avec les dépenses qui doivent
rester au niveau d'un débat national
dont qui a pas nécessité de préciser ce
point et à ce titre gouvernement émet un
avis défavorable
explications de vote
je n'en vois point donc jeu mais on voit
que cet amendement numéro 15 que ceux
qui sont favorables pour l'approbation
veulent bien levé la main s'il vous
plaît défavorable il est adopté je suis
est il d'un amendement numéro 16 de
monsieur gorce abandon qui est complété
d'un sous-amendement de monsieur masson
cette disposition vise à permettre à
tout candidat qui est s'est dotée d'un
mandataire financier de pouvoir saisir
la commission des comptes de campagne et
accessoirement le conseil
constitutionnel qui est le juge de
l'élection d'une éventuelle
interrogations aux contestations sur
l'imputabilité d'une dépense électorale
si on voit évidemment par exemple au
débat qui s'est engagé sur les
déplacements du président de la
république où les multiples initiatives
qu'il prend aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
aux jouets moyens juridiques de
qualifier ses dépenses et éventuellement
de pouvoir les prévenir ce n'est que
postérieurement que la commission des
comptes pourrait éventuellement y
parvenir
paraîtrait plus satisfaisant du point de
vue éthique et du point de vue
démocratique que les règles soient
clairement établies en amont pour que
chacun soit invitée à s'y soumettre
plutôt que sanctionner avec de gros
guillemets monsieur collombat l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure plutôt que
sanctionner très faiblement
après le scrutin et plusieurs mois après
le scrutin
quand tous les amendements que présente
monsieur masson qui consiste à ouvrir à
tous citoyens la possibilité de saisir
la commission des comptes la commission
ne s'est pas prononcé sur le point mais
je n'y suis à titre personnel pas
favorable dans la mesure où il ne s'agit
pas d'organiser des initiatives
multiples qui pourrait évidemment
déstabiliser la campagne électorale mais
devrait être à chaque candidat de
concourir dans des conditions égales et
d'éclairer de ce point de vue l'opinion
publique sur la manière dont il peut se
comporter et de se comportent
éventuellement ses adversaires il me
semble que le champ de cette saisine
doit être limité y compris d'ailleurs
pour des raisons matérielles qu'on
imagine aisément doit être limitée aux
seuls candidats ayant déposé et ouvert
un compte de campagne et choisit un
mandataire merci monsieur mation pour
présenter